will you pray with me spirit of the
Living God come now and start a lesson
new draw us into your word and give us
life I'm in a long time ago Daniel had a
dream we heard a little bit of it last
week but we picked it up right in the
middle so all that stuff about the
throne but having been established and
the one coming with the clouds before
that Daniels dream begins with the
stirring up of the sea and a series of
truly awful beasts they emerge from the
midst of the chaos each one is
successively stronger and stranger than
the last each one more menacing than the
one that came before it and the fourth
and the final one is the scariest of
them all Daniel describes it as
terrifying and dreadful and exceedingly
strong with iron teeth that was
devouring it was breaking into pieces
and stamping what was left beneath its
feet it had great horns with human eyes
and an arrogant mouth spewing noise this
is where we begin the Advent season in
the dark of night on that strange and
scary landscape of Daniels dream and
despite the comforting words of our
parents when we were small we have a
sneaking suspicion that these
nightmarish monsters are alive and well
in our world all too real and wreaking
havoc all over the place there are
armies of iron jawed beasts lining the
borders of Gaza they are rolling through
the streets of Syrian cities they fly
daily over Afghanistan and Pakistan and
Yemen and Gaza and Somalia spewing down
fiery vengeance
others of them are busy blowing the tops
off of the Appalachian Mountains
consuming over 800,000 acres across
Virginia and West Virginia and Kentucky
and Tennessee disfiguring the landscape
permanently and poisoning the life in
the entire region this is just to name a
few these beasts are bigger than any one
of us and yet somehow an extension of us
they are larger than life version of our
disordered desires acting in concert
with one another they are an inflated
embodiment of these desires that are
engaged in a battle for power the power
to exploit and devour other creatures
and even all of creation these creatures
destroy what they did not create and
everywhere they go they are devouring
they are breaking things into pieces
destroying and stamping beneath their
feet what remains homes trees bodies
everything in sight they have they have
human eyes but not human hearts their
eyes see only numbers coordinates and
profit they cannot see people or beauty
or true cost they know no affection no
limits and no loyalty their mouths are
only arrogance Jesus says all of these
things will take place the chaos will
continually increase just as daniel has
dreamt it a chaos that birds these
beastly forms in the world and people
will faint from fear and foreboding and
the very powers of heaven will be
threatened shaken at their core it's
precisely then that Jesus tells us to
stand up with our heads held high as
witnesses to a different truth a
different power a different
for the world we are called to stand up
in this arena of beasts that threaten
permanent night eternal death and
testify to the life and the light that
we find in Christ in this season of
Advent we have been given eyes to see
the places that need God's justice and
God's comfort and God's mercy in the
world we have been given mouths to
truthfully name these things aloud we're
called to call out to others to stand up
and to sit in and solidarity to prepare
the way of the Lord and Jesus assures us
that we will see the Son of man coming
with the clouds this is the fulfillment
of Daniels dream that Christ will claim
full Dominion forever the beasts will
all be laid low the throne has already
been established so even though the sea
has been slapping us around of late even
though there are other nightmares in our
life that haunt us to the point where we
cannot see our way through the next day
the next week the next year we can be
sure sure of Christ promises sure of
Christ Dominion shore of Christ's
salvation for us all we can be so sure
that when we look at the trees they are
barren and nearly dead and yet through
all the months of winter we can wait and
when you see those first buds just
beginning to peek out the shyness of
green and red and white you know then
that spring is surely coming and Jesus
says you can be this Shore and even more
shore because even if the trees should
pass away even if all of creation should
pass away the heavens and the earth
god's word of promise is more solid than
anything that we know anything that we
see anything that we tell
if we should all pass away into darkness
God's Word would remain God's creative
word that said let there be light and
there was light let us rely on that
promise and testify to that light in
this season of Advent amen